well with how many times I've constantly
praised the Toy Story series you would
think that Toy Story Oratory Story 2
would be my favorite Pixar film and
actually they are not that distinction
goes to up in my opinion one of the most
perfect family animated films that has
ever been made it's funny it's emotional
it has memorable characters it's
colorful it's bright stories easy to
follow you get wrapped up in the drama
has tons of memorable moments it's
basically what I think of when I think
of a perfect movie what's the premise a
little boy meets a little girl and they
instantly fall in love well not
instantly he's a little shy and she's an
over-the-top energy holic but they do
have something in common that they both
love adventure and they love to travel
they make a pact that they will go on an
adventure sometime but unfortunately all
sorts of real-life events constantly get
in the way but they live a good life all
the way up until old age until her
untimely death obsessed over the loss of
his wife little boy has turned into a
grouchy old man who's about to lose his
home so he takes matters into his own
hands and ties a bunch of balloons to
the house and takes off into the sky off
to heaven adventures searching for that
patch of land him and his wife always
talked about getting along the way of
course he comes across some colorful
characters including a boy scout who
accidentally got roped in a rare bird
who seems to get along with the boy a
dog named Doug he has now a new
generation of children with that name
are going to suffer you're off the hook
for now Nickelodeon and an old pilot
whose lifelong search for the bird has
driven him insane determined in
capturing the creature even if it means
killing anyone in the way on the surface
the story doesn't sound like much in
fact it even sounds silly and yeah it is
silly I didn't get to the point about
the dogs flying the little airplanes
yeah there's dogs flying little
airplanes in this but if you're willing
to buy surreal ideas like a house that
can take off with a million balloons you
know what you'll buy stuff like that as
well and that's what the film manages to
do it manages to pull you in with every
silly over-the-top gesture because the
dramatic moments are just as equally
strong you immediately identify with the
girl
the boy in the opening and I'm sure
you've heard everybody talk about the
first ten minutes and how unbelievably
good they are and yeah they are my
brother and I used to joke that you
could just slap the end after the first
ten minutes and the audience would
probably be satisfied it's the history
of their life as a couple together
without any dialogue it's all done
through visuals and music and honestly I
didn't think they were gonna top it I
thought maybe they play their trump card
too early but the rest of the film is so
imaginative and so colorful and so
likable that it's impossible not to get
as drawn in as you were the first 10
minutes the bird never says a word and
yet it has a lot of personality the
relationship between the boy and the old
man has its funny moments but it also
has its touching moments the way they
nail the personality of a dog by giving
it a voice box is ingenious even the
side villains as soon as this
threatening hound showed up I remember
thinking to myself oh gee here's the
killjoy no funny things are gonna come
out of this guy but sure enough this had
me pissing my pants all the way through
yeah it's childish I know all they do is
speed up the voice but by god when you
put that voice against that threatening
image it's hilarious
up has the perfect amount of drama
comedy material for adults and material
for children it doesn't need a whole
slew ton of characters to sell toys with
it only needs a couple but the couple
they choose are so good and so likable
that it's all you need I'd say the only
nip ik I have with it is how is it that
the boy is watching the pilot when he's
young and yet when they meet up they
look roughly the same age
no no shouldn't that pilot be dead by
now I kept expecting them to explain
that but they never do but honestly if
that's the biggest problem with the film
I have little to complain about I can't
think of anything else wrong with this
film the love is genuine the friendship
is genuine the characters are genuine
the situation's as crazy as they are
seem remarkably genuine it's a strange
story with strange people but hey how
many great tales have started off with
this is a normal story with normal
people for all these reasons and more if
I even needed more up is my all-time
favorite Pixar film